[Music]
so
hey guys so today i wanted to share with
you guys
the system that i have used to organize
my architectural thesis project
and this system has helped me receive
the aia henry adams award for my thesis
and it has also helped me graduate early
from my master's
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dammy
and i am a licensed architect in
beautiful vancouver bc
on this channel i talk about
architecture and design
and give you some tools and strategies
to help you through architecture school
and in your architectural careers also i
just want to note that i know many of
you have asked me
if i can share my thesis project but i
hope you guys can understand um
this this
300 page book is my thesis project
so i am still trying to figure out how
to take this
and my thesis presentation which was
designed for an architectural audience
like my juries
and my peers and turn it
into an engaging 15-minute
video for youtube so
please be patient and without further
ado
let's just jump right into it so i
organized everything in
onenote this was before
notion i use notion now i have upgraded
but onenote is really good for
just some simple two three level
organization
and that's kind of all i needed when i
was doing my thesis
so it's divided into notebooks
so i have my thesis notebook
and within the notebook you can have
different chapters
and within the chapters you can have
different
sections and i also have my
thesis folder
and it's a little bit of a mess
but please don't judge me i just want to
show you
how i have created the structure um
within the structure i have not really
kept it super organized
um but i think it'll still be helpful
for you to see
so i'll go through that as well
so i did try to create a pretty good
structure
for what i was doing every single day so
um july august that's when i really
started researching
for my thesis and so this was like
during the summer between my first and
second year of masters
yeah so a little bit about how my thesis
was structured
so the first year was really focused on
exploring
different aspects of architecture that
you might be interested in writing your
thesis on
so the first semester
we researched all of the firms
that were participating in the chicago
biennial
we were given like two three firms to
research each person was able to
pick um a couple of the firms that kind
of aligned with their interests
and write a sort of manifesto and
do a little presentation on those firms
and how they aligned
with what you wanted to pursue it was
also
about learning how to represent things
in a more conceptual and theoretical way
and it was kind of
getting an understanding of what a
thesis was
um and then in second year that's when
we
started like the thesis process
and the summer between the first year
and second year that's where you're
supposed to
do all of your research like all the
background research that's supposed to
build a foundation for your thesis
you're looking at your precedence you're
getting the list of all your readings
and like trying to do as much of the
reading as possible
um you're looking at other projects or
other theses
that could relate to yours
you're looking at the possible
sites and yeah like you're basically
doing all the background research
and that's also when it's not really
structured right
you have basically
sort of may june july and august without
too much contact with your supervisors
and so it's really like self-initiated
research
and so i really wanted to create
um some sort of a structure for myself
so that i don't
waste too much time um
you know not working during that time i
was actually
traveling i was in italy and um
it was actually a nice time for me to
just like
read and relax you know chill on the
beach drink some wine
and yeah that's sort of where i did a
lot of my research
you will see that it has fed into my
pieces
quite a bit
okay so here i just sort of outlined all
of the things that i
wanted to get to um
in this month
and like every day i try to make a
little
goal for myself so
july 19th just read the little bit of
the umberto echoes how to write a thesis
and if you haven't read it like i would
really really highly recommend that you
read that book it's a really easy and
fun read every day
i would make some tasks for myself
make some notes for library at night
reno marito echo
and just also tried making
some notes at the end of the day
on the progress that i made so
on july 25th i wanted to gather thoughts
on the topic and collect a bibliography
and some photos
and i my progress was
i organized the writing gather thoughts
on the rhizome warburg library and
stephen johnson's
it's jason possible quotations from
books
are the all there but means personal
summary and a synopsis of why it is
important for the thesis
yeah having a collection of like what
you did at the end of the day
actually even fed into my thesis and it
kind of helps you
see at the end of the week or at the end
of the month um
how much progress you actually made and
you can kind of see oh
like wow i really didn't make any
progress on these days
like well maybe i should change
something about
how i was working so yeah
and then september 8th that is when i
had
um my meeting with my second reader
so i actually typically um
collected my meeting minutes in the
meetings folder
but same thing like i made some
general goals for the day and try to
schedule out my days as much as possible
you can see here that i started writing
my progress
or like my thoughts at the end of the
day in red
here i made a red note to myself i
skipped the gym today
uh from two to three went to library
until 10
studied exeter library seven hours that
seems like that took a really long time
why did it take so long
but it was very good information now how
the f do i put that
into the presentation oh also i skipped
the gym today
this must have been very close to the
presentation because i had quite a lot
of things that i was supposed to do
and then here october i think this was
like right after my very first
presentation
and so i kind of just took the notes
from the presentation
here on the side and i tried
to create a task list
out of that um
try to divide that throughout the month
and you can see how i have created some
task lists
here and yeah that's pretty much the
structure of it march
final push april
wrap up
and then here i have my meetings with my
supervisors
so these are basically my meeting
minutes
and it's kind of a collection of like
what we discussed
at the meetings because very very very
easy to forget
so always always always good to have
something written down
um and then writing this is
the chunk of what makes
a thesis look like this
and as you can see i went through many
many many
many iterations of the writing
and you know there isn't really one of
the things that i found
really helpful is just to
create an initial table of contents so
yeah here
and then presentation these are kind of
like the notes
or the script that i wanted to talk
about during my presentations
um milestone
[Music]
and i also had the feedback from my
presentations in here
substantial completion
[Music]
and books this is um
yeah something that i really wish i had
started doing
at a much younger age but every book
that i would read i created a section
for it
and i would write down my notes
so what i did is like um
typically like i would read
a book and like you know it's kind of
hard to be like reading and
taking notes reading and taking notes so
i would like um
have like a million tabs and i would
just like
tab the sections that i would want to
write down
in my notion in my onenote
and as i go through the book and
um like let's say i finish a chapter in
one day i would have like five tabs in
that chapter
and at the end of the day once i'm done
reading that book i just like
sit down and spend 30 minutes just like
writing down everything that i
read that name and just go back to the
tabs and if there's any quotes i want to
take i would just write it down here
and i find it really helpful to do that
after
every reading session rather than
waiting to
finish the entire book because by that
time like you will have lost some of
the really valuable information so
yeah that's what i've found really
helpful and so
i've collected all of these
notes from all these books and these are
going to be super valuable once you
start
writing and bibliography you will have
to prepare
the full bibliography of your references
initially i had organized it into
sections
just for myself so all the books that
were pertaining to
libraries i collected in this session on
reading i collected in this section on
the warburg library i collected in this
section on culture i collected here
but i think in the end i ended up
consolidating everything into one
bibliography
because that's sort of what they ask
for and they typically want you to
organize it in like an alphabetical
order this is like the standard way of
organizing your bibliography
um by the alphabetical order of the last
names of
the authors and i had a section for
precedence
um so i divide it's a little confusing
so
precedents are basically
all the literature or projects that had
been
done about my thesis topic by other
people
so this guy justin watch
he had done a thesis
project called library in the labyrinth
so
i collected his thesis here
and yeah like you as soon as you
kind of have an understanding of like
what you want to write your thesis about
you want to go and
research all the other written material
or thesis
that has anything to do with the topic
that you want to talk about
and just try to get a sense of like what
has already been talked about
and what you can learn from that
and what you can reference in your
project and then case studies
are the case study projects
so i have like oma's library
um oma seattle library
the warburg library and of course i
have the corresponding folders
that actually have drawings and
diagrams of these libraries in here
but this is all the written information
about the library which is also
really important for your research for
the articles i pretty much just like
copied and pasted the entire article
and whenever i found
like a quote or sections that were
interesting i just highlighted them
like that
and any quotes that i could use any
information
about the site so i had some site
options written down here
um and of course venice
venice was the site for my thesis and i
visited venice many times
um so these were kind of like all the
locations that i wanted to
visit while i was there and
any key terms that are important for
your thesis
and uh umberto echoes library that's
kind of specific to my thesis because i
was creating a library that was
collecting all of umerto echo's
50 000 books and
he also had a very unique library
so these are pretty much like all the
articles that talked about his library
um and then i will show you my folder
structure
so please don't judge me it is very
messy
but um this is how i organized
my thesis folder so uh in
writing this will be like my
indesign document for my thesis
booklet and inside precedence i would
have
each folder for each building that i was
studying
so um
like the beineckey library
i just collected any diagrams or
drawings i could find
any photos or any scans from books
um and for instances where i had
multiple buildings from one architect i
just created the name of the architect
and um created the
folder for the building
i think if you are collecting like
hundreds of thousands
of case studies then it makes sense to
have
it to be very very very organized but
you know this kind of was enough for
what i was doing
so that was
sort of it and then within the design
folder
i would have my drawings so diagrams
elevations
um experiential section plans
renders sections and
inspiration any inspiration images that
i could apply to my
thesis and
yeah i tried to create
folders within this
as well and instagram like anything i
wanted to post on instagram
um and in the model folder is where my
digital models are
um physical model i have
like basically laser cut files
and pdfs for um
for my physical models and oh i also
have like photographs of my
actual physical models
and prints are just like whatever i
wanted to print
um for desk credits or presentations
and process like i did try to keep a
pretty good record of like all the
sketches that i did
um you know just in case you might want
to come back to it
and a lot of times you're sketching on
trace paper and
trees paper can get pretty
pretty nasty and it can get crinkled up
or ripped up
so it's good to have a digital copy
of all of that i think um and then
any site information see i had
photos of the approach to my site um
drawings of the site conditions
and in reference images i had like any
images that i was using for my renders
so for photoshop files and materials
yeah like materials that i was using for
my renders
and same people for renders and diagrams
and readings any pdfs of the readings i
was doing
um any scans of books that didn't make
it into the
precedence folder and thesis precedence
any thesis that i was looking at
like theses that other people had done
that i was looking at that related to my
topic
um and presentation oh god
this boulder is such a mess
um as you can see and this is probably
because i was like rushing rushing
rushing rushing oh my god i have to
hand something in for my presentation
and i just like never took the time to
actually organize these properly
and a part of me really wants to
go in and organize it but a part of me
is also like
i don't really know if it's worth my
time
and then any meetings i had with my
supervisors
i tried to um
take a good record of in
the um onenote
and in these ones i think i had
like documents that i wanted to show to
my supervisors during the meetings
and the book is like my final
book like the final thing i think
everyone has a different way of
organizing their theses but this is how
i did it and it worked for me
um try to keep it a little bit more
organized than
i did but i think my strategy was just
to um keep a pretty
good record of everything i was doing
every single day
and also i just tried to keep a really
good record
of everything i was reading and
everything i was looking at
um just because you are going to
encounter
so much material uh when you're doing
your thesis
and a lot of that stuff did make it into
the book
and um because notion and you know
sorry not notion because onenote and
pr notion as well and you know pretty
much all
of the digital note taking software you
can sort of
um go into like the search bar
and search for a word and it'll show you
like
it'll show you like all the sections
that this word is in
so that's a really helpful way of
filtering out information i also have
some other videos like
how to present case studies and how to
present your work in a compelling way
i will leave them up here hopefully you
guys found this helpful
and if you found this helpful please
give me a thumbs up and
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments and i'll
try to get back to you i will try to
make more content
about architectural theses um because
this
i had a lot of fun making my thesis and
i think if you
you know kind of start doing your
research early and you
find a topic that you really like you
will have an incredible
incredible time